hello there rejects we're back at it
again podcast format this time we're
talking about something incredibly
relevant in today's world it's all the
talk of the fandom
these days it's all over the Internet
we're talking about The Maltese Falcon
Falcon that's right the kids are going
out of the gourds over that Maltese
Falcon see ya man's right let me see one
of our top reward tiers on patreon is
whatever video you requested was
definitely doing put up on YouTube every
once in a while we get asked to do a
discussion and not a reaction and I'm
very grateful for those and rare is the
day we're asked to review something I
think the last time there was something
so old it was not for rot - and that was
a lot like something that was just a
discussion and not a reaction ok so
apparently what people want a discussion
that's not a reaction it's gonna be some
really old a [ __ ] yeah yeah now we you
know I hope that we can get
progressively older is you know like not
you came way before this I think now we
got to go back and like review the Great
Train Robbery or something like that you
know eventually we'll be doing the first
movie yeah I know we did do a reaction
or not ferati talking about yeah that's
not be first
that's true but we did do it but the
discussion but it was a reactant yeah we
did not do a reaction to Maltese Falcon
a few months ago David Gandy this is his
request he he actually sent us over a
few movies three and one of them was
this movie and I hadn't seen it until
very recently it was sometime within a
week ago or whatever that I watch this
movie for the first time and what goes
into this is my girlfriend
olivia is a huge huge huge fan of
classics that's her favorite genre
easily without a doubt there's no other
genre that can outdo classics for her
and she knows that every once in a while
I'm gonna have a hard time paying
attention to a classic
and so before turning it on I just asked
her like okay this is am I gonna be
bored
am I gonna be bored I'm really curious
about how the story turns and she's like
probably you're probably bored and I'm
like whoa come on there's been plenty
that I actually did like you're just not
giving me credit then it services like
bickering thing about the ones I
actually have enjoy thinking now I've
turned on and I'm like whatever just pay
attention just pay attention to this I'm
sure either way I'll go to appreciate it
my way to approach a movie and I did not
love the movie emotionally okay
especially the first upon first viewing
I did find myself randomly reflecting on
it and really appreciating this movie
it's a it's a really well crafted movie
it's like to my surprise I did not know
its history and I did a little bit of
research on its history and knowing that
this is like literally the defining film
noir yeah yeah it is quintessential like
the thing is to discuss like the plot
points would be like oh yeah that sounds
like the quintessential film noir and
then you go back and you're like oh this
is the criticism what film noir wasn't
even an established thing again yeah
this was this was like an introduction
to what would eventually become coined
as film noir and I found that
fascinating because as I was talking
about the movie with Olivia you know I
would use the word trope and trope has
become such a negative word like if you
bring up oh the trope it's an
automatically sounds like a negative
thing but I didn't find any of the
tropes to be in a negative experience
because I found myself going yeah I've
heard of all these tropes I've seen
these tropes in other films you know
cold-hearted detective the only thing it
doesn't have is like this is like
internal monologue you know yeah but so
you have the cold-hearted detective you
have the femme fatale and distress at
first who really has a secret upper
sleeve hey you know like multiple
double-cross yeah they've got the big
heavy with with Casper and what nine
there's a lot of cold
characters in this movie so I wasn't I
wasn't upset by the tropes instead I was
impressed by the tropes which caused me
to look it up and go oh this was
actually like the invention of the
shirts no wonder it's done so well yeah
at least in cinema I mean that was
adapted from a book and stuff so yeah
and I and I'm from what I read the
director who was pretty accurate
wouldn't adapting it to the actual
dialogue featured in the novel cut out a
few things here there but it was and I
also found it to be crafted very well
yeah like a lot of the times when I
watched these classic films is black and
white films I noticed they're usually
heavily reliant on script and actors and
the directing is kind of you know
whatever they directed with the actors
but in terms of symmetry
sequences shots composing those elements
I find that to be kind of lackluster
with classic films just and you always
give it the benefit down like it's an
old [ __ ] movie you know yeah this
probably was more innovative at the time
and people weren't so much like oh we
got to make everything visually crazy
well yeah I mean watching this movie I I
did find myself impressed by a lot of
sequences and the way they were captured
a lot of very specific like there's
symmetry in a lot of the way this movie
is is captured and there's even of a
very big awareness of increasing tension
and increasing energy in terms of its
pacing that I just wasn't expecting
walking into this movie because it's
easy to disregard a classic film you
kind of expect a certain type of movie
you know and watch it you know this is
actually a really impressively crafted
film with some really killer
performances in this movie and yeah this
movie I think sings in large part thanks
to the cast like the cast the main cast
like the five-ish characters that are
kind of core this story really are
top-notch because it's such a dialogue
trivets it's mostly just scenes of
interplay between people and and
double-crosses and details to keep track
of and that could easily be very dry
yeah and I feel like they really avoid
that
thanks to the remarkable choice of
casting and just what each actor brings
to their respective roles you know
absolutely absolutely
I found Humphrey Bogart especially
fascinating I mean he's probably you
know this is one of his defining roles
ever oh yeah and I can see why because
what's the word I feel like I want to
say morally ambiguous but then I'm like
I don't quite know what that means but
the word that comes to mind
big Lluis is sort of like you can't
exactly tell if there's this particular
moral code at play so you know you'll
kind of find somebody with the line yeah
and that's a very film noir trope
private detective who kind of plays a
loose with the law but he has his own
kind of code at the end of the day he
lives by and that's kind of the ultimate
reveal with his character while there's
like twists and turns and zigzags that
kind of happen in this movie the reveal
of his character is he has a code yeah
such a rewarding a thing at the end when
he's like talking straight to her and
he's like you know maybe I love you
maybe I do but I just I know too much
about you and I know what you've done to
my partner and it's my obligation in my
part like he lays out his philosophy and
he touches on that note he's like as
crooked as I'm supposed to be you know
this is how I actually get by yeah and
it was very three-dimensional and very
layered because you could tell he is he
is tempted by these greedy things he is
tempted by arguably he does give into
some elements agreed but at the end of
the day like he says there there's a
certain thing about even though I was
sleeping with my partner's wife he was
my partner and you killed him and I
gotta live by that like he just can't go
against that code which I found to be a
really interesting sort of reveal in his
arc because you are kind of when you're
watching the movie you're like this guy
just is so impartial to like everything
yeah this guy's seen it all he's clearly
smart yeah you can outwit everybody and
and knows all the cons and everything
yeah I like how the script is also very
aware of that
who's that actor I've seen them like
several classic films he Peter Lorre
Peter Lorre yeah as Joel Cairo yeah
Peter Lorre in that movie he does have
some line of he'll is something where he
acknowledges that Humphrey Bogart always
has a response yeah he's always so
smooth and quick to come up with a
response and it's easy in these kind of
films or so much of it relies on rhythm
of dialogue to kind of look past that oh
yeah of course he's like that's that
kind of movie but the film itself is
aware of just he's always got something
clever to respond with yeah when I feel
like this is a film that is good at
earning those elements and making them
feel natural whereas other movies lesser
film noir you might go oh well yeah it's
film noir so of course he's quippy of
course there's clever dialogue blah blah
but this I feel like Humphrey Bogart has
a special talent for delivering that
kind of hard-boiled detective dialogue
and making it like he's got that perfect
demeanor where he's kind of got those
likes half sleepy eyes but he always
looks a little sort of bemused by the
things that are going on like he really
exudes this quiet confidence you know
yeah and and yeah this is also a Sydney
Greenstreet first movie which I didn't
exactly realize at the time who played
Casper the the big guy whose whole thing
I loved that intruder my hatred he's so
great cuz like the his whole intro he's
like you know he's talking about
Humphrey Bogart's mannerisms is like I
love a straight talker I love a guy who
gets right to there and like everything
he's pointing out is exactly what he
doesn't do yeah you know he's such a
great foil of a character and and to
have him in cahoots with Peter Lorre to
my favorite scenes were with that when
those who are interacting it's not like
most of the movie but when those scenes
happen like one of my favorite sequences
I love a one-shot take where you don't
realize this one shot yeah that's not
the point yeah yeah yeah check yourself
and go oh it's one shot it's the scene
when Humphrey Bogart is drugged he they
had this dialogue where the negotiating
back and forth and he's just drinking
away because that's his character his
characters an alcoholic and he's just
drinking away drinking away it's
one negotiation take that's really
composed well and then you and then if
you like really pay attention Casper the
actor Sydney green Sydney Greenstreet is
the city you could tell that he's kind
of just waiting for the drug to kick in
but he's buying time but in movie
doesn't in such a non obvious way
because it's supposed to be an illusion
of deception that you think they're just
really having a full-on negotiation when
that's not the case of what's actually
happening in that moment you know and
that's what I mean by very specific
direction in this film like there's a
good amount of like panning around and
everything like that and the would some
interesting shots of I remember when he
first gets the phone call that his
partner dies like that for some reason
the shot is just only on the phone when
he's having that phone call in his
dialogue with whoever is on the other
line is off screen and I just love the
unique choices this movie took with it
and they got the Casper Goldman Guttman
Guttman that when the IMDB says okay
Kasper Gutman is a really really
energetic yeah I I have looked it I had
to look it up
who plays Cairo oh it's named Peter
Peter Lorre Peter Lorre I've seen him in
a couple of other things and Peter Lorre
in this movie I just kept asking myself
it's it's character gay yay I always
wonder I feel like there's always kind
of I feel like that's just Peter Lorre
but I looked it up and in the book his
characters gay oh really
yeah but back then with censorships and
stuff like a wrong no yeah yeah because
there are a little nuggets there I get
the impression he's gay or am I being
homophobic the crafty [ __ ] that's what
they call gaydar people well-honed
and I mean Peter Lorre is just is such a
quintessential actor in a way like
there's nobody like Peter Lorre like you
the second you see him on screen just
understand why so many Looney Tunes are
filled with parodies of this yeah
because he's and and the thing is he has
such a big presence and a big
personality and there are movies where
you can assess
him as being very big and very kind of
cartoon-like and I feel like in this
movie especially he plays this sort of
percolating energy where it's like you
know he's clearly kind of squirrelly and
sniffly but it's also a bit more of a
not subtle but just a lower key you know
Peter Lorre it kind of fits the scale
yeah well was he European or something I
think he's like German or Austrian yeah
well Europe a lot of those actors are
very much trained to be very expressive
and used their body language a lot they
they they really really train in the
theatrical the theatre in that way so
when I watch his performances I'm like
yeah it's a theatre performer right
there yeah that's the vibe I get when I
want to watch him and I think I think
he's great uh Eva Archer as Gladys
George no wait no Gladys George played
by E Berkshire that's right
I'm really I'm glad when I have an irony
me in front of me and I'm reading it
wrong that's nice not the one I want to
touch on well that's on top the Mary
Astor yeah as Brigid O'Shaughnessy that
was really fascinating performance
because I like as a man who's slightly
familiar with film than wash ropes at
least being educated on it I was really
just sold she was damsel in distress at
the top of the movie hmm and then as
things start unfolding in the matter
even my time you get more involved she's
yeah everything you might have time to
get to the very end
ah you really don't know you have no
idea
does she's crying and everything over
she's gonna be arrested and and I love
you but but do you yeah
and does he you know see I felt like he
was at least very tempted to not turn
her in yeah and he had to fight against
it yeah we're with her you're like this
is she I can't tell I can't tell and
that's a good job on the perform yeah so
like characters like a Rebecca Ferguson
and Mission Impossible rogue nation
wouldn't exist
oh really well done characters like her
way back then yeah like this is the
classic femme fatality can you trust her
or not yeah I wanna and I love Mary
Esther's performance in that role partly
because at least for me she's not
exactly who I think
when I think of you know like the femme
fatale of a film or I think of you know
maybe somebody more like a nun janu of
some sort and she's got you know a
different kind of presence I don't know
she's got this kind of high class and I
don't know like she's very pretty but
she's not like you know like a bombshell
necessarily yeah that's kind of
sophisticated beauty and this again the
energy that she operates on she's always
kind of selling her emotions and trying
to convince him of stuff well I think
the director does such a good job at
knowing where what his performers have
to really communicate at the time
because all the reveals with her
wouldn't work well if you didn't truly
believe she was just some damsel in
distress at the very beginning of this
movie and and Plus you have Humphrey
Bogart half the time like every time
he's talking about her off screen he's
he's basically like I took it for
granted that she was lying about
whatever he told me yeah so every time
we see him away from her it's kind of
reminded that you know we can't trust
this person very much even though yeah I
love that ambiguity it brings to her
character because she does feel like a
real carrot like having you wonder about
it there is potential for her to be a
real authentic character or be just a
complete manipulator because like when
she gets into the elevator at the end
that look on her face is pretty cold
yeah you know and that's also that's a
terrific like that shot has always stood
out to me when the greats close on the
elevator and the shadow lands perfectly
over her eye with the three notches like
one of them is is Spade one is Guttman
and one is uh I noticed that I thought
that's just me extrapolating Cairo but
you know like that's kind of how I took
that at the time is like the three major
players who you know getting involved
with them led her to this you know other
times being behind these bars Oh
fascinating that's just kind of me
extrapolating but and there are some
like really you know even though these
movies aren't as visually crazy there
are some shots that are gorgeous in this
movie and I mean film noir is known
partly for its expressive use of
lighting and shadows and stuff like that
and there are like that's a great
example of that there's also that scene
where oh who is it
when Wilmer when Wilmer comes to and
it's just a close-up on everyone's
yeah looking at it man and that like
that's basically the establishing shot
for that moment and you're like oh yeah
if I was in this position I would know
right away I am screwed
people been plotting about me yeah it's
it's is really in this thing this
director was his first film or something
like that one of his one of his earliest
once as there were other actors they
wanted for it but they refused to work
with him because he was so new or
something like yeah man I forget I
forget what I specifically read on that
but it was one of his like first films
or at least he was an unknown director
at the time first film on was his first
yeah man yeah that's it I bet a lot of
people kicked this he's got a pretty
prolific catalog as well and I also I
think it's just a great blend of
management you know it's a lot of times
in movies like this you walk away with
the impact of the mystery but they they
tend to forget the character and it's
not like this movie is insanely
expositional like there's only one
really big huge character reveal moment
and that's the very end but you are
slowly learning about who these people
are and this obsession like well they're
freaking out over the fact that this
Nazis Falcon isn't real
they're still going for it yeah
afterwards just embark it's it's like
they live more for the journey then they
do for the end that's all this yeah [ __ ]
they lose their serialism lose their
[ __ ] and then immediately after that
readjusts it's like okay well goes good
going on this event it's like that's
what they live for is this obsession in
this journey that it's not about them
obtaining it which I found particularly
interesting you know is weirdly all this
talk about The Maltese Falcon and
getting this damn thing I feel like
nowadays a lot of movies might execute
that improperly to the point where most
audiences are like don't [ __ ] they
don't even get the phallus any worse
yeah exactly what it was pretty simple
to watch this movie and go oh it's not
even the point
you know yeah what is how [ __ ]
obsessed a yeah
that's that's a funny thing is is I know
we have both been watching a ton of
those Screen Rant pitch meetings yes and
one of the jokes that I keep catching in
those is about subverting expectations
and how that's not just about taking the
thing we expect and not doing it it's
doing that for a and I feel like this is
a movie that yeah when they finally get
the Falcon and they're like this this is
a fraud it's useless that is like a an
earned subversion of expectation because
it says something yeah about everybody
and especially how they respond
afterwards yeah you know and and so much
of this movie is about those things
about like the idea of something turning
out just not to be true it's all the
lies that get told it's all this fuss
over nothing nastácia never truly line
up with how they've presented them and
even the thing they're going for is an
actually real I guess the one thing that
could be left open to interpretation
that I kind of felt like I I would have
liked a little bit more resolved on was
everything to do with his partner's wife
because it was established really on the
film they were having an affair
sometimes came back into play like be
like one point she I think she calls the
cops on them and the cops show up
because she's like jealous and obsessed
but it doesn't really resolve and that
was that was probably the one thing
where I would have liked a little bit of
resolution cuz I'm like I know he's felt
all this guilt and stuff but this is the
ending telling me too that with all that
he's come to realize he's now gonna not
sleep with his partner's wife or
something I'm not sure and I didn't
particularly hate the fact that he was
doing it because he seemed like the
partner was trying to have like hook up
with the main actors I'm forgetting all
her name I'll watch her and all that so
you know yeah it seems like you kind of
want her to do something with her yeah
yes so it's okay yeah well don't worry
in actually in the first 10 minutes of
the sequel she dies and then he's got to
investigate her murder okay yeah yeah
yeah it's a lot of times in movies like
this it's hard to blend
plot-driven movies and have just enough
character in there to make it worthwhile
and I feel like the characters kind of
sprinkle throughout to its ultimate
reveal of who these it's like part of
the mystery and raveling of it is who
are these people really yeah and I
really love that that's the real mystery
and you have to figure that out through
their behavior and through kind of
training your eye to the things that Sam
sees because just none of the explicit
text of the movies actually gonna tell
you who these people are you know it's
all about paying attention in their
behavior and stuff and I feel like for a
classic film it was surprisingly easy to
pay attention to because sometimes for a
person who didn't grow up on classic
films I feel like if you grew up on
classic soup your parents made you watch
classics or something like that it can
be easier to watch those kind of movies
you know and for me I didn't I just
didn't grow up on these kind of movies
and it hasn't it's only been in the past
couple years where I've been watching
more of them and sometimes they're very
hard to pay attention to and sometimes
they're very easy to pay attention to
and I would say this is one of the ones
that after all these decades of there's
a viewer who's used to more fast paced
entertainment this was surprisingly very
easy to sit back relax and get a lot
from so yeah I feel like this is one of
those movies that is just of a certain
level of quality that if it's like one
of those bands you go see where you're
like you don't even have to like this
band but if you like live music you'll
have a good time and I feel like this is
one of those movies where it's like you
don't necessarily have to be into this
it's just well-made enough to be
compelling it's like I react I remember
back in high school we watched this in
my film studies class I mean I've seen
the film a few times through the course
of my life but that was one of them and
I vividly remembered that in my film
studies class just most of my fellow
classmates were not about these movies
we're not about the older more classic
stuff I think we watched some other film
noir joints as well maybe even
Casablanca I know we watched Citizen
Kane people were not about those movies
but I do remember I being kind of
pleasantly surprised that after The
Maltese Falcon was done people were like
and yeah I feel like you know that is
kind of a mark of excellence on this
movie because it has yes so much that
inform the genre it's got all the
double-crossing it's got all the
archetypal characters it's got a
terrific cast even down to like Wilmer
you know it's like Alicia cook junior
who's been in a bunch of you know
classic old movies as well like the
crucial roles are cast really well the
story is intricate but when you go back
and look at it you can see kind of all
the sees yeah yeah threads you know it's
it does kind of take you back to a time
where like nowadays things are more
sensational and even in the construction
of movies a lot of stuff happens there's
a lot to consider and when you go back
to a movie like this I think about focus
you know it feels just like a really
focus really ironed out yeah because
like I said earlier at the talk of this
one thing that especially surprised me
was its awareness of pacing because
there's about a halfway point in this
movie where the pace released it's not
like the movie just gets more
interesting the pace starts to really
increase the intensity the music starts
to shift yeah like everything starts to
get faster paced because the situation
is intensifying and I I really
appreciate that attention to deep this
to me is a good example of the fact that
I haven't I'm not I'm not that familiar
of these movies so I'm very familiar
with the tropes and it's it's easy to go
oh seen these strokes before or whatever
I was not aware this was the first of
them yeah I was not aware so this is
also a good example of just because it's
a trope doesn't mean that it's
necessarily bad it's a good example of
execution more than anything else
yeah because eventually you're going to
be removed from the timeline of which
movie came when and stuff and every
movie just needs to work on its own yeah
and so you know you can see these these
threads throughout so many films and and
this one just does them well you know it
plain and simple so if it didn't it
wouldn't work as well it's a great movie
thank you David Gandy for asking us to
talk about it and I appreciate it was
really well worth the time at a great
time watching and if you guys haven't
seen Maltese Falcon I don't know why
you're sitting through this
you just like encourage your friends to
go check like I don't know what this is
but I like your review style very
definitely a smart of the movie yeah
yeah you might wanna I'm just kidding
the multi they find it they don't I do
I'm not gonna tell ya anyway guys for
the hundred people that watch this video
or listen to it because it's a podcast
you can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell and check
us on patreon we've got a lot of goodies
over there
take care